y
alexander y elena buscan en las ruinas
de su casa
ya tenemos vida
dios por ti y
estábamos aquí en el corredor cuando la
casa fue bombardeada nos habíamos
escondido y salimos cuando paró todo
cayó sobre mi mano mi cabeza tratamos de
protegernos a 150 km de la capital
ucraniana la ciudad de dormir no está a
salvo de los ataques rusos a principios
de marzo un nuevo bombardeo también
había hecho destrozos en zonas
residenciales pero a pesar de esta
angustia y resiliencia vamos a
reconstruir todo
vamos a plantar nuevas plantas
reconstruir la casa los cimientos están
sólidos construiremos a partir de hoy
oleksandr y elena viven actualmente en
un apartamento prestado por un amigo que
huyó a francia con su familia el
recuerdo de los bombardeos de esta noche
permanecerá durante mucho tiempo
ya estoy tomando medicamentos ya no me
quedan lágrimas
la casa de la pareja está ubicada a unos
cientos de kilómetros de la sede de la
95 brigada de asalto aéreo una de las
unidades más prestigiosas del ejército
ucraniano que estaba en la mira del
ejército ruso del otro lado de la vía se
encuentra la maternidad de hitomi allí
el personal hospitalario hace todo lo
necesario para adaptarse al contexto de
la guerra actualmente trabajamos en el
subsuelo durante la noche si tenemos una
urgencia sólo trabajamos aquí aquí
hacemos cesáreas y partos naturales
también me gusta mucho mi oficio y si
escucho voces voces de recién nacidos
ello me impresiona adoro eso escuchar su
voz y no el ruido de las bombas su voz
es la paz es excelente 13 mujeres
estaban presentes en el hospital durante
nuestra filmación algunas esperaban para
dar a luz otras acababan de hacer tal
como victoria quien nunca había
imaginado que su recién nacido nacería
en tales condiciones
es un regalo y le agradezco el personal
médico haber trabajo en condiciones tan
difíciles
condicións
y las cosas que hicieron son increíbles
y lo que hacen
nos dieron esperanza a nosotras las
madres y nuestros hijos
mirando a su recién nacido por esto no
logra contener sus lágrimas
no le deseo vivir
lo que sentimos ahora
es una catástrofe
espero que se termine lo más rápido
posible
victoria no es la única que tuvo que
huir
aquí en gin tonics la ciudad se volvió
un centro de acogida para todos los que
huyen de kiev y de las regiones
bombardeadas esta familia que acababa de
huir de justo mel cerca de la capital
vivió bajo ocupación rusa no hubo ni pan
durante dos semanas nada en los
almacenes las tropas rusas robaban en
los almacenes iban de una casa a otra
arrancaban las cerraduras y las puertas
le gritaban a la gente vayan a rusia
ucrania es el mal rusia es el bien
cuando nos fuimos ya no teníamos gas lo
cortaron diciendo que era gas ruso nos
escondimos
abandonamos nuestro refugio cuando ya no
había columnas de enemigos
teníamos miedo incluso cuando escuchamos
las sirenas en grito mir
pensamos que nos pueden alcanzar aquí
también
este padre de familia sigue sin entender
el sentido de esta guerra su territorio
no le alcanza
no les alcanza los que más quieren de
ucrania soy un novato cory jane es ya
julio
antes de continuar su periplo más hacia
el occidente esta familia recibe ayuda
en un centro como éste
aquí los equipos hacen hasta lo
imposible para atender todas las
solicitudes
yo voy a llorar nubes de chat a prost en
este jardín siempre que aterrice señor
pero las solicitudes no conciernen
solamente a los desplazados desde el
principio de la invasión rusa los
precios de los alimentos están al alza
lo que impide que muchas familias puedan
hacerle frente a sus necesidades
todo esto volvió mi vida imposible toda
mi familia está desempleada y depende de
mí no es la primera vez que vengo aquí
antes vivíamos con las reservas de
alimentos que aún teníamos las
solicitudes de otros residentes que no
lograron familiarizarse con el sistema
puesto en marcha fue rechazada nos
dijeron que no podíamos obtener ayuda
mientras no estuviésemos inscritos pero
no sé cómo hacerlo no es difícil usar
internet sería más fácil si pudiésemos
inscribirnos in situ y obtener ayuda al
día siguiente
que se trate de acoger refugiados
distribuir ayuda humanitaria o brindar
seguridad a las ciudades los alcaldes
juegan un rol crucial en este
dispositivo en la alcaldía el alcalde de
youtube ya sergi sur holding nos confesó
no haber regresado a su casa desde que
empezó el conflicto la amenaza es
omnipresente incluso durante la
entrevista que nos concedió
sirenas sonaron una vez más
tremosa saluden
tomamos nuestra cámara y nos dirigimos
hacia los refugios estas alertas suenan
en hitomi durante todo el día obligando
a la población a refugiarse en lugares
seguros
continuamos la filmación en el refugio
de la alcaldía donde su home link
antiguo suboficial del ejército
ucraniano nos habló de la foto colgada
detrás de su escritorio un retrato de
mahatma can group cuyos valores
pacifistas eran cercanos a los suyos
pero ante la imposibilidad de dialogar
llevar armas se volvió inevitable para
él
unos cuantos días antes de la guerra
hablé con la gente con la que me entrene
y ahora sirve en rusia les dije que
pasamos mucho tiempo en la escuela
militar
todos comimos de la misma olla muchos y
dormimos bajo el mismo cielo tocar y
ahora somos pero si vienen aquí los
mataremos
y defenderse contra el enemigo y
defender su propio territorio es lo que
siguen haciendo los ucranianos e incluso
si las tropas rusas parecen desviarse
actualmente de la capital kiev en
gitomer como en otros lugares muchos se
preguntan si podrán retomar una vida
normal próximamente